indeed it is awesome but how does this
affect performance well note the
sequence of steps here when we encounter
the script tag
we had to pause Dom construction and let
JavaScript run before we could continue
javascript is set to be parser blocking
because it blocks Dom construction when
we encounter the script tag I see but
that doesn't seem like that big of a
deal
javascript is pretty fast right it is
but let me make a slight modification
instead of using an inline script like
what we have here on the bottom let's
say we move the script contents into an
external file like what we have here
what would you expect to happen now hmm
well same as before the parser finds a
script tag fetches the file and executed
oh wait oh I see this fish could take a
while right and while the browser's
fetching this file the browser's blocked
and can't continue constructing the Dom
which would in turn slow down the
critical rendering path exactly the
script tag blocks the parser from
preceding and we're stuck waiting for
this file not a good outcome
so if external javascript always blocks
the parser it sounds like I should just
inline all of my JavaScript well yes and
no you're right in that in lining the
JavaScript would help eliminate the
request but there's some downsides as
well for example if you use the same
code on multiple pages then that would
be redundant code in all those pages so
there are trade-offs here all right
but for code that's specific to one page
that seems like a pretty good strategy
yeah that's reasonable but let's take a
look at some of the trade-offs and the
gotchas associated with them